this is a production of Cornell
University so this is you know kind of a
comparison of the NRCS programs versus
what we're doing in just Maryland which
has a pretty robust program this is a
collaboration with my PhD advisor and
with Dean hive Lee and some folks at
USGS and ARS so it's it's developed out
of a larger program and we're just kind
of trying to add value to it I do want
to say that this was supported by
northeast sare so thanks to anybody
who's from Sara here so cover crops are
very regionally diverse in their
adoption you've got some areas
especially out in the Midwest where it's
you know zero one percent and you see
that these are zero to one percent one
to five percent five to ten percent and
then you see these red areas 15 to 56%
and that's where Maryland is leading the
way we have really high adoption rates
there's a couple other areas of the
country that you know localized pockets
but Maryland is really the star and I'll
talk about why so already this was my
title are they working and tell you yes
they're working really the question is
how well are they working so here in the
Northeast we're especially interested in
protecting water quality because of the
Chesapeake Bay largest estuary in North
America it's very ecologically and
economically valuable to the area it's
also very densely populated as we know
as well as dense with agricultural land
and you know it's got ten billion
dollars of agricultural output so it's
not it's not something to overlook and
Maryland is almost a hundred percent in
the Chesapeake Bay watershed so there
was political will in Maryland to really
focus on protecting the bay and so about
ten years ago a little bit more they
came up with this program it's different
from
the way the NRCS programs work in that
it's available to every farmer every
year you know there's never a cap on how
many years you can do it there are caps
on how many acres but it's sort of like
an enormous number for a farmer so
that's not really an issue and the idea
is not so much to incentivize like the
real enthusiasts it's to get everybody
it's not just the true believers this is
just money in the pocket so compared to
the payments for equip in say Indiana
this is twice the amount of money I mean
this was my first time singing the New
York numbers that you just presented
which are comparable to these numbers
but this is a lot more money than a lot
of other states are providing through
the NRCS programs and farmers like this
a lot more than you know some of the
other governmental programs about cover
crops for example in Denmark there are
mandatory cover crops and they don't get
much choice so farmers like to get money
instead of just being told you have to
do this so the way the program works is
the farmer in the fall will make their
plan for the coming season they'll go to
their so a water conservation district
and they'll say okay I've got this many
acres I'm going to plant and this is how
I'm going to plant it this is how I'm
going to terminate the crop you know
this is the species that I am planting
all of this information is entered into
a big database and then the payments are
scheduled based on that and it's really
simple compared to the NRCS programs
where there's like a bunch of different
options it's like just basically did you
plant it by October 1st if you did then
you get this extra bump in pay for being
early did you plant it by the 15th well
then you get a bump for being sort of
the standard type thing and then there's
a late time thing after that we really
incentivize cereal rye because it is
just so much more productive than all of
the other species so that gets an extra
$10 bomb but then the entire purpose of
this program is
just water quality it's just keeping
nitrate out of the Chesapeake Bay
so legumes and leggy mixes which we're
all really enthusiastic about as we're
proud you know true believers are not
really incentivized in the program
because that's adding nitrogen to the
soil yeah now the the sort of
interesting thing is this harvested
column for many years of the program but
not this year the program
allowed you to plant a grass in the fall
as long as you did not fertilize it
until the spring and then harvest it for
green the following summer and so
obviously wheat is a big option in the
region
people are really enthusiastic about
that this is the first year that they
are cutting that side of the program out
now you get a lot less money for that
but you know that's just sort of on top
of I don't know probably read somebody
caught them basically is what you're
saying I'm not I'm not super sure about
every so kind of an update from the
numbers that we were just talking about
it's actually 22 and a half million
dollars this year so it's it's a good
chunk of change especially because
Maryland is a relatively small state you
know this money wouldn't go that far in
you know say Iowa but was really far in
Maryland yeah so the kind of questions
that we want to address in the project
that I'm working on are are these
incentives working sort of over time you
know since the inception of the program
has adoption increased
are these cover crops capturing and and
keeping me from getting into the bay and
are the payouts sort of on the level
with the amount and so we're gonna
tackle that in a couple different ways
and talk about a couple different data
sets that we have doable so like I said
spoiler alert our incentives working
well they absolutely are so this is a
trees over time
[Music]
and you see that has gotten to be the
largest drop in the state on a given
year and part of that is driven because
of the wheat program that and the other
small grain commodities that promote
most of the programs you were able to
enroll those program but then it's also
just you know this is now you know 54%
of our entire state crop land program in
here in this 2016 it just keeps going up
every year but then the question is you
know what's the interaction between the
timing of these various operations or
the types of management that people do
and the amount of money that we're
spending so this is you know average
planting or each field across all of the
years and this is following corn and
orange and following soybeans in the
green and you can see that the dates are
very clumped together here the days are
coming together here where you know
they're sort of a they go up then they
go up and then they and then they drop
off well
imagine those days by $5 you get an
extra five $10 and then the actual final
date of the program varies years
trailing off there so we see this real
incentivization for farmers to say I'm
gonna drop everything in make sure that
I get it planted on the very last day
possible you know money bump but that
pales in comparison to the fact that
they all want to kill it on the very
first eligible date I mean now all this
is you know like 10% but so come March
1st they're all up there spring under
this be then they just want to get out
but then after you know that first 10%
of folks you have this kind of long tail
of you know when the various kill dates
are some people are going all the way
into May and then the June and July is
[Music]
and so then the question is you know
over the years of the program have these
incentives that we really want people
with have they increased in popularity
so you recall that like early planting
gives you an extra 10 bucks since you
would expect that you know from the
second in 2004 when they were only
offering $20 so now in 2016 where you
get a maximum bonuses are people going
for that top rate and they're really not
there is either you know early plantings
are actually going down late plant
things are going up little change in
no-till and really no change in adoption
3 all right so I'm gonna take away from
this is if you allow
but they're not willing to change their
operations they're not willing to change
their so it's if the money is not really
driving and why are we so concerned with
early planting and late killing well the
programming problem from our perspective
the policymakers so this is sort of like
your potential 23 days on the y-axis
versus and this is from the Y Research
Station on the Eastern Shore which is
and so I've got here the number of
growing degree days you might accumulate
until first and then the first date
you're eligible to kill March 1st and
then through sometime in the spring
maybe easily in the fall there isn't
very much we tend to have similar
weather every year and get a lot more
growing three days I plant early two to
four times but then we might have a warm
winter where by March first you've
accumulated a lot of growing degree days
or we might have a cold winter where you
know you've had very little change from
January to March so you don't see a huge
increase we see them start to spread out
and then going into spring and we know
that is what really drives biomass
biomass is what's going to drive nitrate
accumulation the problem is the whole
point of the program is to accumulate
nitrogen in the fall
so that's part of why the program is not
really incentivizing later kill dates
already lost we not really the point of
the program
oh okay gonna set that time and start
playing with it so the way that we
wanted to answer some of these questions
we've got a combination of some field
studies and some remote sensing so we
identified a bunch of sites over on the
Eastern Shore this is near that Y
research station and these are all very
sandy soils they're almost all alton
soils like textured and like I said
these are the top counties that are
enrolled the number one County the
number four County in the number three
County and you see there a bunch of
other top tens you're on the Eastern
Shore as well as a few in central
Maryland and so we went out anyway so we
went out and by we I actually mean
[Music]
technology alright so and see and then
in the spring after green out as they're
started took samples analyzed them for
CNN and here you can see the real
difference between a cold beer and a
warm here
a cold year you accumulate very little
biomass from December to March in a warm
year you can accumulate two to four
times as much biomass from December to
March so you know that's something that
we think is really valuable but that's
what farmers are afraid of a lot of
farmers who don't want to have that you
know high residue and so as far as this
program is concerned as long as you're
getting something here that's a success
and the question is is that enough to
success for phosphorus loading and all
the other things that spring
are not being targeted by the program so
the program you know has some diversity
in it there's radishes and there's like
you mixes but 90% of the farms enrolled
are cereal rye barley and so this is not
super important but basically this is
all of the management practices that the
farmers are reporting and did some
machine learning algorithms on it see
the big cluster together and so they end
up forming these clusters where people
who are planting after soybeans and the
plant late they have a variety of
establishment that this is a variety of
species but this is sort of one of the
clusters and then you've got people who
are camping we got people who are doing
broadcasting various varieties people
were planting barley and we're planting
right so those are sort of some short
hands to think about these different
clusters that came out in the data and
and it's reasonable to assume that these
management practices would vary so then
the question is how did these come from
perform in these clusters that I just
came out with and just as a reminder you
know after soybeans means late wheat
barley and rye drilled small grains and
then broadcast is often earlier by you
know either aerial or just broadcast
after the crop is harvested and you know
this is the details of the model so you
see that we've got these nice lines that
connect them and some are much deeper
than the others and in fact it's
statistically significant that rye
outperforms all the other clusters and
then our two small grains are next and
then we've got our broadcast owner after
soybeans pulling up the rear and so what
that means is
Rai is just always going to be more
performant than just going to more
biomass it's going to salvage more
nitrogen no matter when you but then
you've got and and you know you would
expect that you're really barley would
do well but not as well and what's
interesting at out of this is you know
even if you plant after soybeans even if
you drill in if you plant a good species
like right you're never going to get
that fuel performance because the slope
of this line just isn't high enough no
matter how far out you go in these
growing degree days you're not going to
get there
and and that's a real challenge so it's
basically telling us that if you don't
get and likewise with the broadcasting
no matter how early you get it in if
you're not getting good soil seeds
you're not going to be getting good and
it's never going to be able to catch up
to your you know sort of well-managed
species so then this is sort of the
final surgery date a bit if you look at
this is kilograms of n that is in the
biomass in the spring divided by the
number of dollars and very consistent no
matter whether it's in the commodity
program or if it's traditional ever
table doesn't matter if it's you know
between the different clusters here rise
a little bit better but you know the the
median this heavy black line is pretty
similar so that kind of answers our our
last question of are these payouts the
ones there
is one metric that you might use and so
the next step of this is that we're
going to extend this analysis to use
biomass estimates from and then we're
going to test these relationships across
soil and so just a quick conclusions to
drive performance and the small green
subsidy we're available in the program
achieved a lot of the singles of crops
so any other question that Extension
sociological component things like is
very variable among different areas
there some district agents who are going
to be very hands-on and and there are
others who you know are not right i I
don't know that the state has that on
their radar you know when I read through
the meeting or the yeah the meeting
notes those or the most recent planning
committees you know they're they're not
even thinking about trying to optimize
the program they're just trying to keep
it going
oh I don't know and based on what Dean
just told us
sounds like probably huh because if
they're sort of shifting it from an
incentive to a regulation
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu